- Halloween II would literally pick up
right where the original left off,
but that would not prevent it
from subjecting the story
to some major changes,
like some lore and motivation
for the mysterious, masked antagonist.
Police find the word Samhain,
or as Loomis says it...
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- Written on a chalkboard
at the elementary school.
The significance is only briefly explained
by Michael's psychiatrist, Dr. Loomis.
He mentions that it's a Celtic word,
meaning Lord of the Dead,
that the festival of Samhain
signified the end of summer.
But the meaning and
connection to Michael Myers
and the overall message of Halloween II
goes much deeper than that.
It actually refers to a Gaelic festival,
marking the end of the harvest season
and the beginning of the
darker half of the year.
In the Northern hemisphere,
it is observed starting on
the evening of October 31st
and ending on the evening of November 1st,
much like Michael's rampage in this movie.
It begins on Halloween night
and carries over into the
first day of November.
Early literature says that
Samhain was celebrated
with the opening of ancient burial mounds,
which were seen as portals
to the other world,
which may have been opened
with bonfires and sacrifices.
Maybe Myers' defeat at
the end of the movie
is symbolic for its connection
to these Samhain festivals.
It is believed that over time,
Samhain merged with other
cultural celebrations,
eventually becoming Halloween
as we know it today.
So, it may come as no surprise
that this word may be the key
to understanding everything else
in the undertones of the
original Halloween sequel.
For my entire analysis,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by BetterHelp.
(rock music)
(gun blasts)
Six gunshots would not be enough
to keep Michael Myers down,
just as dozens of angry mothers
would not be enough to stop
me from making another episode
of Things You Missed.
Once again, I'm joined
by YouTube's resident Halloween
expert, Jimmy Champane,
or as Dr. Loomis would
pronounce it, Jimmy Sam Hain.
- If that's how he says it,
I don't even wanna
imagine how he'd spell it.
- [Zac] Last time, I broke
down the psychosexual subtext
of the 1978 original.
So in this episode, I'll
introspect the 1981 followup,
Halloween II, the first of many attempts
to create a direct sequel.
- Writer-director, John Carpenter,
initially wasn't interested
in continuing the story of Michael Myers,
but then he said, screw
it, I do like money.
So, he returned to produce
and write the screenplay.
He also decided to
collaborate on the score.
So, directing duties would
initially fall on Rick Rosenthal,
but Carpenter didn't like
what he came up with,
so he reshot some scenes,
and then he still didn't
like the finished product.
- Listen, Jimmy, I'm not
gonna get into the drama,
but I am going to get in
to the Things You Missed.
(eerie music)
The opening of this film,
takes us back to that fateful
Halloween night in 1978
and we fade in backed by
the song "Mr. Sandman,"
by The Chordettes.
We hear the lyrics, "Mr.
Sandman, bring me a dream."
This is the first of many
references in this movie
to the idea of dreams
and the unconscious mind.
Mr. Sandman is a myth
from European folklore
and serves as a stand in for
another mythological man,
The Boogeyman, an alias
that is commonly used
to refer to Michael
Myers in the first movie.
- What's the boogeyman?
- As a matter of fact, it was.
- The lyric specifically says,
"Mr. Sandman bring me a dream."
Throughout the movie, Laurie
is terrified of going to sleep,
perhaps because part of
her subconscious mind
knows that her dreams are
where she'll see her brother
and nemesis, Michael Myers.
We do see a glimpse of one of those dreams
when she dozes off at one
point at the hospital,
though it's unclear if
she made the connection
about who this mysterious boy actually is,
but one way or another,
she seems terrified
of the idea of seeing
the backs of her eyelids
ever since her encounter with him.
It's the first thing she
tells the ambulance EMT
and she reiterates it for the doctor.
- No, don't put me to sleep.
- And there's even a deleted scene
where she uses sheer willpower
to keep herself awake.
- Is she awake?
- Dr. Mixter gave her a double bullet.
If she can keep her eyes
open, she's made out of steel.
- She actually falls asleep eyes open
when the medication fully kicks in,
a testament to just how much
she wanted to avoid seeing
that dream at all costs.
The beginning of the movie
takes us back to the final
five minutes of the original,
with a couple of shots
giving us a new perspective
on those events.
- In a way, this was a
taste of things to come.
Rick Rosenthal would go to extreme lengths
to shoot this movie in the same style
as John Carpenter's Halloween,
and what better warmup exercise is there
than adding shots to an
already existing scene.
This is followed by a long
POV shot of Michael Myers
spying on the neighborhood,
which is, of course, a direct
callback to the intro shot
of the original Halloween,
where we see the world through
young Michael Myers's eyes.
Both scenes feature him
looking through windows,
sneaking inside and then stealing a knife,
all while no one seems to
notice that he's there.
Both scenes are also important
from a filmmaking standpoint,
because one-takes are
notoriously expensive
and challenging to get right.
So, a little movie like Halloween II
nailing it as hard as it does,
really helped it to stand out
from the growing pool of competitors.
And that pool was growing
extremely quickly.
- [Zac] Michael looks in on
Mr. and Mrs. Elrod's house.
- No, not that Mrs. Elrod.
- Mr. Elrod is watching
Dr. Dementia's Horror Movie Marathon,
a continuation of what Lindsay Wallace
and Tommy Doyle were seen
watching in the first one.
We continually see this on
TVs throughout the night,
whether it's George Romero's
Night of the Living Dead
or the 1955 horror film, Dementia,
a movie involving a woman
caught in a nightmare cycle
that deals with the horror
of the subconscious,
kind of like how Laurie
feels that she's trapped
in an inescapable nightmare with Michael,
which affects her so badly
she's mortified at the
idea of going to sleep.
- [Eerie Voice] Now, back to Dementia.
- When I covered the original movie,
one symbol that I pointed
out time and time again
was the use of bedsheets.
We were always seeing
Michael through these sheets
and I interpreted that
as part of this metaphor
for his tendency to go after these teens
that were trying to go
to bed with one another.
There is one hookup couple
that Michael takes out in Halloween II,
which may be the most brutal
scene in the whole franchise,
but the main theme of this film,
if I had to pick just one thing,
is the idea that Michael is
this never-ending bad dream.
In that sense, the bed
sheet motif still works,
now being given a different meaning.
It's associated with the dream
where Laurie discovers that
she's related to Michael,
an idea that festers in her subconscious,
but her conscious mind doesn't wanna face.
- One constant in nearly all
of John Carpenter's projects from the time
is the use of the actress, Nancy Loomis.
She's the woman who played Annie
in the original Halloween,
but her death in that
movie doesn't stop her
from appearing a few times in the sequel.
I'd say chances are pretty slim
you didn't miss when Annie's body
was brought out of the house
and identified by her father,
but you probably didn't
notice that she plays Sally,
the girl on the other end of the phone
telling her friend about
what's going on in Haddonfield.
- [Sally] Didn't you hear?
- Hear about what?
- [Sally] Some girl got
killed in Haddonfield.
It's on the radio.
- While there are still plenty
of Halloween I callbacks to discuss,
there's also a potential look
at the future of the franchise
in the form of one seemingly
random side character.
(menacing music)
Do you find that you're not happy
or something is blocking you
from reaching your
maximum potential in life?
It's time for you to get
some help, some BetterHelp.
BetterHelp is a
professional therapy service
securely operated online.
No more going into the office in-person,
no more sitting on the couch like this,
which is what I assume,
happens at these things.
You'll connect to a worldwide network
of over 20,000 therapists
who are guaranteed to be
licensed professionals.
You can easily log in
to your account anytime
to send a message to your therapist
and you'll get timely
and thoughtful responses.
You can also schedule your weekly session
via phone call or video call.
That means you're gonna
be saving money on gas
and sessions are already more affordable
than the traditional
therapy with the couch.
Imagine if Michael Myers used BetterHelp,
how much better thing might have gone.
I guarantee your BetterHelp doctor
will not try to shoot you six times.
- And fired six shots into him,
he just got up and walked away.
- Visit betterhelp.com/CZsWorld,
that's better, h-e-l-p,
and join over one million people
taking charge of their mental health.
As a CZsWorld viewer, you
get 10% off your first month.
Just click the link in the description
in betterhelp.com/CZsWorld.
(eerie music)
Shortly before Laurie's ambulance
arrives at the hospital,
we see a mother taking
her swashbuckling son
into the emergency room.
He's bleeding profusely from the mouth
and when he drops his towel, we see why.
A huge razor blade is
jammed into his gums.
This calls back to an urban legend
about tempered Halloween candy.
I remember when I was a kid,
my parents would always have to inspect
my trick-or-treating haul
to look out for any wrappers
that might've been altered
in fear of a malicious
neighbor possibly poisoning
or putting foreign objects into the candy.
That's the implication here.
Michael Myers is not the
only evil in Haddonfield.
Longtime Halloween fans know
that Michael wasn't intended
to be a recurring character.
John Carpenter and Debra Hill
planned to make it an anthology series
about various scary stories,
all taking place on Halloween night.
That's why Halloween III
has almost no relation
to the first two movies.
This pirate costume kid
almost seems to foreshadow Halloween III,
which, spoiler alert, features
an evil company's plots
to harm trick-or-treaters.
With so much of this movie
trying to match what happened in the past,
this one character looks
towards Halloween's future.
Soon after, we're introduced to Karen,
who was on her way out
of a Halloween party.
In true Karen fashion,
she has a little bit of a public freakout.
Roll it.
(digital whooshing)
- I'm never going to
another Halloween party
as long as I live, especially
not at Stevie Mathis' house.
- This is our first crew
reference Easter egg
because Steve Mathis is the electrician
on this movie's credits.
The only other one that I
can say definitely exists
is in the staff locker
room at the hospital,
where one of the lockers
is labeled Cummings,
which has got to be a self nod
by a set decorator, Peg Cummings.
- In order for director Rick Rosenthal
to fully immerse us in
the world of Halloween,
there are many specific callbacks
to specific moments within
the first Halloween movie,
like how Karen suggests
her friend gets a ride home
from a Halloween party,
from a guy named Eddie Lee,
to which she responds...
- He's in Russellville.
- [Jimmy] You might also remember
that the Haddonfield graves keeper
mentions a town called Russellville
in the first movie.
- I remember over in Russellville,
old Charlie Bowles, about 15 years ago.
- [Jimmy] When looking
at the news coverage
of the murders on Orange Grove Avenue,
one of the EMT's bud
makes this comparison.
- It looks like a goddamn homecoming.
- It's a really
interesting choice of words
because one of the main plot points
in the original Halloween regarded Laurie
and who she would choose to go
to the homecoming dance with.
- [Annie] Well, you could ask Dick Baxter.
He'd go out with you. (Annie laughs)
- I'd rather go out with Ben Tramer.
- [Zac] Ben Tramer also makes
an appearance in Halloween II,
or at least it's heavily
implied that the masked kid
who gets slammed by a
police car was Tramer.
- Yeah, I'm worried about Bennett Tramer.
- He isn't home yet.
- [Boy In Blue Coat] Yeah
and he left the party at 10.
- You're just gonna brush past the fact
that the cop who just hit Ben Tramer
going 50 miles per hour,
gets out of his car and says,
"I didn't even see him."
Like you can't even give him
the benefit of the doubt on that one.
- That part is pretty funny
if you're looking out for it.
And I just love how the cop
basically goes out of his way
to hit the kid.
His body is totally burned up,
but the forensic dentist
also seems to think
that the victim is probably
around Tramer's age.
On a night that feels
like it can't get any
worse for Laurie Strode,
Michael Myers is indirectly responsible
for the death of her biggest crush.
Halloween has become the nightmare
that she can't wake up from.
Then there's the security guy, Garrett.
When we first meet him,
he's reading a newspaper.
Let's zoom in on the headline here,
a dead ex-con with six
bullets in him will float.
This probably refers
to the lung float test,
an autopsy procedure that
can help pathologists
determine the true cause of death.
But what I'm more interested
in here is six bullets.
As you probably know if
you've seen the movie,
Dr. Loomis loaded Michael with six bullets
at the conclusion of
Halloween in the Doyle house.
He proceeds to bring this
up whenever possible.
- [Loomis] Tell the sheriff I shot him.
I shot him six times.
And fired six shots into him-
- You couldn't have shot him six times.
- You think I'm lying, sheriff?
- Speaking of Loomis,
there's also a scene
where he and the police
discover that Michael broke
into the elementary school.
That's where they discover
the Samhain graffiti
that I mentioned earlier.
When they enter the classroom,
they come across a childlike
drawing of a family of four
with a knife stuck into the sister.
Obviously, we're led to believe
that this represents Judith,
the sister that Michael stabbed
in the opening of the first movie.
But we later found out
in the infamous twist
that Laurie is Michael's other sister
and this drawing shows
that's the reason he's coming after her.
If you look closely,
you'll see what appears
to be another figure
laying in the grass colored in red.
I'm guessing that's supposed to be Judith
and this is Laurie,
who Michael is threatening with the knife.
The bigger question I
have is who drew this?
Have Michael's art skills
not progressed since age six
due to his incarceration
in the sanitarium?
Are we supposed to believe
that he made this drawing in kindergarten
and it's just been filed away
at the school somewhere ever since?
Or maybe it's just another kid's drawing
that he repurposed to
send his own message?
- Just don't even think about it.
Things will be better for you, I promise.
- To be honest, I have a lot
of questions about this movie.
Like, how did the media find out
about the babysitter murders
before the sheriff of the town?
Why does Loomis put his
face so close to Laurie
when he's asking if she's okay?
- I'm sorry I left you.
Are you all right?
- That's so weird.
And why are there no
holes in Michael's mask
after Laurie shoots him in the face?
Are we supposed to believe
that both of those shots
went perfectly into the eye holes?
Michael is 21 years old in this movie.
It's even called out by
Dr. Loomis at one point.
So, why do the credits
say Michael Myers, age 23?
They actually made the same
mistake in the first movie.
But if you do the math, he is 21.
Not sure how that happens.
Why does Michael's mask look
so funny from a low angle?
Was this entire thing just
an elaborate ruse by Jimmy
to get a lap dance from Laurie Strode?
- Men, you can't live with 'em,
you can't live without 'em.
- Yeah, I don't think
that's how the saying goes.
Help her out, Lloyd.
- Women, can't live with
'em, can't live without 'em.
- Words of wisdom.
The other question I've
always had about this movie
comes up in the third act
when Loomis, Marion Chambers,
and the state marshal
show up at the hospital,
not realizing that Laurie is
injured in the parking lot.
I always found it pointless,
how she waits until
after they've gone inside
to scream for help,
but in analyzing this
movie, the scene fits in
with the bad dream theme
that's been established.
Not being able to find your voice
totally sounds like
something that would happen
in a nightmare.
I can even remember having
dreams like that as a kid,
and then waking up to find
myself mouthing the words
with a dry throat.
I think the line
that ties this movie's
themes together the best
comes when Loomis explains
the rituals of Samhain.
(digital whooshing)
- In order to appease the gods,
the Druid priests held fire rituals.
Prisoners of war, criminals,
the insane, animals,
were burned alive in baskets.
- It is interesting that
when he brings up rituals,
he specifically mentions burning alive
because, as we all know,
that's Michael Myers' fate in
this movie, at least for now.
And that iconic shot of
Michael Myers burning
might be yet another direct reference
to The Thing from Another World,
which was referenced very
heavily in the first Halloween,
which was again,
a teaser for what John Carpenter
would go on to work on.
- By observing the way they died,
the Druids believed they
could see omens of the future.
2000 years later we've come no further.
Samhain, isn't evil spirits.
It isn't goblins, ghosts or witches.
It's the unconscious mind.
We're all afraid of the
dark inside ourselves.
- "We're all afraid of the
dark inside of ourselves."
The idea that I've come back to
throughout this entire video.
The idea that Laurie
knows in her subconscious
that Michael Myers is her brother
is the terrifying reality
of this Halloween night.
A reality that makes even
evil spirits, goblins, ghosts,
and witches seem tame by comparison.
The idea is hammered
home by the final scene,
bringing the story full circle.
Laurie is right back where she started,
moving on to yet another hospital.
The ambulance disappears
into what looks like a foggy dreamscape.
The news station, WWAR,
who we heard the initial reports
from about Michael Myers,
is now on the scene getting coverage
of his latest sets of victims.
Michael lies face down on the ground,
seemingly defeated once more,
and the song that takes
us into the end credits
is none other than the song we heard
when this nightmare began,
Mr. Sandman, bring me a dream.
This ending was meant to be
the death of Michael Myers,
but as we now know,
the character was just too
profitable to stay dead.
However, the next Halloween movie
focuses on a completely different story,
earning at the title of black sheep
of the Halloween franchise.
Another big thanks to Jimmy Champane
for breaking down this sequel with me.
- Thanks again for having me on, Zac.
I usually talk about new news
related to the Halloween franchise,
so it's always nice to go back
and look at where it started.
- I'd like to tell you to
go subscribe to his channel,
but legally I'm just not allowed to,
but I think just between you
and me, you know what to do.
So, join us in the next
episode of Things You Missed,
as the season rolls over
and we discuss Halloween
III: Season of the Witch.
Remember, subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring that death bell
for all notifications,
and I'll see you in the next
one, assuming we both survive.
(eerie music)